φιλοδου θυσέα ότι δεν υπάρχει τη συζητήση δεν υπάρχει ατομό υπάρχει ατόμο σήμερα στο συναγερμό
που λέει ότι πρέγα πάμε σγκέρση που λέει ότι πρέπει να ξεργόνα ένοιξεο να ξαμπούμε
στην κείναπούμε ριστηρίζχριστοδουλίδη τις λεμνες πρόεδη γα δεν υπάρχει αυτό το πράγα ενώ σε επίπεδο
διεργασιών έσιν το σκέεφται κάποιος αν τσυζητείτα κάπου αν τιλιπτόν αλλά δεν υπάρχει ανιχκτά εσύ
πως βλέπεις τούεν όλη την αντιπαράθεσης τελεγχόν του κόμματος προσφατα ακόματαις ίσιως σε μια συζήτηση
με τον κύριο φέδονος καλεσμένις επώτιχας προείνα υπουργής τελέχει βάλουντα με πρόη προέδρος θεωρίσε ότι
μόνο κακόν κάπνει ενόψη των βουλευτικώ του οέξη όλοι αυτήκό να που υπάρχει μέσα στο
δημοκρατικό συναγερμό όταν γίνεται προσωποβαγής ότα γίνεται προωπική η όποια επίθεση είναι κακό για ένα
σύστημα πολιτικό ο οποίο το οποίον έσει μια πρέπει να αυκάλη προσταξουμια στόχευση σισυγκεκριμένι όταν
είναι όπως ήταν με το φίλο εδονα η διαφωνία μου εμέναντραστό μαζί του που ήταν
σε επίπεδον ιδέας ίταν σε επίπεδο προσωπικώ εν έχωκάτημετο με φίλο των φεδονα θεωρώ ότι
μόνο καλόν καμνι αυτόν επάνταεγινε όταν στον δημοκρατηκό τηςσυναγερμό δεν έγνετα κάτι διαφορετικό το ερώτημα
ννι πιον το έναυσμα ωστόχος για να γίνει τογια να γίνει του τη συζήτηση αν
οστόχος είναι να συσδηήσουν για ν ηδέα δηλαδή στην προκιμέ προθήσουμε οφέδο να είναι η
γενήκευσε είναι σωστη υτό ήταν η διαφωνία μας οι γεννήκες συπου γίνεται δεν είναι σώστη
αν υπάρχου στιχία πολύ καλό καλώς να πά στηντ